good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight Kanye West now known as
yay is one of the best-selling musical
artists in the world he's also in recent
years becoming celebrated and very
highly paid fashion designer and of
course for a decade he was well known to
TV audiences as an in-law of the
Kardashian family but it's West's latest
Incarnation is a kind of Christian
evangelist that brought us to his office
in Los Angeles today for the interview
you're about to see
days ago during Fashion Week in Paris
West accompanied by his friend Candace
Owens unveiled a t-shirt that read
simply White lives matter
the response from the fashion industry
and international media was
instantaneous and uniform shock horror
rage there is no excuse for this
thundered the New York Times West is
legitimizing extremism shrieked Rolling
Stone
etc etc
what was strikingly missing from the
coverage whoever was any explanation for
why West did this what was the T-shirt
about
no one seemed to think to ask him much
less to listen to what he had to say
instead the enemies of his ideas
dismissed West as they have for years as
mentally ill too crazy to take seriously
look away ignore him he's a mental
patient there's nothing to see here
but is West crazy
you can judge for yourself as you watch
what we're about to show you he has his
own ideas we can say that creative
people tend to that's why they're
artists not actuaries his free-form
social media posts give the impression
of a man channeling his rawest emotions
right onto Instagram the effect can be
jarring and it's often used as
ammunition against him in the battle for
influence over the minds of America's
young people and that battle is intense
but crazy
that was not our conclusion in fact
we've rarely heard a man speak so
honestly and so movingly about what he
believes but again you can judge for
yourself here it is
so you just came from Paris Fashion Week
you just landed and you're a lanyard's
still on from it and there's a
photograph on it what is that it's a
photograph of a baby's ultrasound
why is that and that you designed that
yes why what does that mean uh it just
represents life and pro-life
boy so you wear it on a badge what kind
of response do you and and good amen I
agree I don't care about people's
responses I care about the fact that
there's more
black babies being aborted and born in
New York City at this point that 50 of
Black Death
in America is abortion so I really don't
care about people's responses I perform
for audience of one and that's God
I'm starting to see why they want to
make you be quiet
um how when did you start to feel this
way when did you start to realize this
I I really felt like I think I started
to really feel this need to express
myself on another level when Trump was
running for office and I liked him and
every single person in Hollywood from my
ex-wife to my
mother-in-law to my manager at that time
to you know my my so-called friends
slash handlers around me told me like if
I said that I like Trump that my career
will be over that my life would be over
uh they said stuff like people get
killed for wearing a hat like that they
threaten my life they put my life they
basically said that I would be killed
uh for uh
wearing the Hat I had uh someone called
me last night and said anybody wearing a
white lives matter shirt is going to be
green lit and that means that they're
going to beat them up if they wear it
and I'm like you know okay green like me
then
you know you know God builds Warriors in
a different way I don't know if it's
because of me being a born in Atlanta
and growing up on the south side of
Chicago that you know
he made me for such a such a time like
this it's like with David
you know he tended to the Sheep but
while he was out there he had to fight
all kinds of animals so when it was time
for Goliath to come he thought because
he was a sheep herder that he didn't
have the skill set to take down Goliath
and the thing that I have is the
position I have my heart but the number
one thing is we have God on our side and
for the people even if you don't believe
in God God believes in you
so you made reference to the White lives
matter t-shirt you brought out at Paris
Fashion Week why did you do that and
what did it mean
you know
I did I do certain things from a feeling
I like I just I just channeled the
energy it just feels right
it's using
a gut instinct a connection with God
and
just Brilliance you know like as if you
ask like Tonya Harding how she did the
the triple flip or the triple spin
she was in so much practice that when it
was time for her to skate in a in a
competitive format it just happened like
it happened outside of practice that
happened in the real format and that's
what hap that's what's happening is God
is like preparing us for the real for
the real battles and we are we are in a
battle with the media like the majority
of the media has a Godless agenda and
their jokes are not working this whole
like oh yeah he's crazy and all these
things they don't work because the media
has you know they've also
watched travesties happen just even
specifically to me and just watch it and
act like it wasn't happening and they
stay quiet about it
um
I want to answer the the white yeah I
feel like someone caught what I was
saying the comparison of Tonya Hardin
about the the white lives matter you
know my dad is a educated
um ex-black Panther
and he put a text to me today he said
White lives matter
and I said I thought the shirt was
a funny shirt I thought the idea of me
wearing it was funny and I said dad what
do you think it was funny he said just
just a black man stating the obvious
yeah
and
you know my dad doesn't listen to rap
music and he's like super educated we
opened up a water Distribution Center in
the Dominican Republic together he's
like the original Steve Jobs but he was
getting blocked every which way with all
of his ideas and he didn't have an
endless bank account and he didn't have
Instagram so all these ideas he had to
like take him back and
compress him like my dad is the most
brilliant person that I know and we
actually have a strained relationship
because I was taken from him because my
mom was an actress so she was a liberal
and my dad would see certain things and
say you know we should do it this way we
should do it that way and the people got
around my mom and pulled her away much
like you know Kim is a Christian but she
has people who want her to go to
interview magazine and put her ass out
while she's a 40-something-year-old
multi-billionaire with four black
children and this is what how fashion
wants to
how they want to present her so I know
you give these um you get these
questions and I give you like these
three-part answers this is a cool format
for you yeah I love it okay cool and I
am following it all right
so you said
um that your father said when he saw the
shirt white lives matter it's great to
see a black man stating the obvious so
by which I think you meant that's
obviously true yeah that my favorite
response because I kept on thinking like
you know people they're looking for a
explanation and people say well as an
artist
you don't have to give an explanation
but as a leader you do yes I think
that's right
so the answer to
why I wrote White lives matter on a
shirt is because they do
it's the obvious thing yeah
why why do you think that's so and I
assume the implications of course all
lives matter because they're lives
because God created them yeah why do you
think that that would be considered
controversial
because
the same people that have stripped us of
our identity and labeled us as a as a
color have told us what it means to be
black
and the vernacular that we're supposed
to have
my dad
grew up as a military brat
and his family moved around but they
were based mostly in Delaware
and at the time
if if he wasn't if they weren't the only
black family they were one of the few
and he would be discriminated against
because he was black
so by the time he got into college
he would be discriminated
against he went to a black college he
would be discriminated against because
they said he talked too white yes and
then he played the kick drum in the band
so when he would go to the club
and the music was playing where would he
clap his hands
where the kick drum is yes it was the
opposite of where everyone else right he
was clapping their hands
and
this is the most elegant and tasteful
person that I know
and
when my mom when they when when the
school suggested or like the herding
systems because what they do is take the
uh the black community and they separate
us and they separate the families and
the educated
uh you know they pushed us you know need
for higher education and us as blacks we
discriminate against each other and say
well I got my PhD and you don't have
your PhD so I'm better than you and so
my mom she had a PhD and she was
influenced to move to the south side of
Chicago and take this job at Chicago
State University and she told my dad if
you come if you come for us you know
you'll never see him again
because you know the media ridiculed me
for getting the house next door to him
to see my children
and they even said that I was stalking
her and her new boyfriend because I
bought the house next door to see my
children and that's that's how I knew
that that uh that my mom had said that
to him I said dad you know they moved us
to one of the most danger agreed upon to
be one of the most dangerous places in
the world it's almost like they tried to
kill me or something uh
I said dad why don't you ever why'd you
never come to get us
and that's when he told me that's when
he told me that she was told that you
know so many things that are put in
Kim's head you know they bring
influencers like no one ever knew where
Corey Gamble came from no one in the
fashion world knows where Gabby came
from
these people were practically made in a
laboratory
in my opinion
and one of the things that they're
really good at doing is being nice and
being likable
and what they do is for people that have
some form of influence whether it's an
educated black woman like my mother that
became the head of the English
Department of Chicago State University
or whether it's the most influential uh
white women on the planet being my
ex-wife
they have people
that are around them at all times
telling them what to be afraid of
it's like not what to do or say
specifically it's what to be afraid of
and if you have a person that isn't
afraid of them
you know
like
a Russell brander yeah kind of sew-ins
right it's not that we have to agree
right with this but they're not afraid
they're not afraid to State what their
opinion is yes everyone no one is God
and everyone has an opinion
so a conversation like this is a window
into a world that you don't see so if
you're familiar with west from the media
you think of him as an individual man
what you don't think about is that he is
at the center of a battle and people
like him at the center of a battle to
get a message out
mouth by the lips of influencers like
him and so many others
that extends a storyline on behalf of
well in this case the status quo so
there are a lot of people vying to make
certain that people like him say the
right things and the consequences for
not doing that are very severe so for
him to come out and say all lives matter
obviously is a huge threat to a lot of
people who are those people exactly well
we asked him and he told us that's next
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight